good morning everyone and thank you for
joining us for this fantastic pnp
webinar with tim jerome the road after
pmp pdus and the skills that will take
you ahead now of course we all know
that uh
getting your pmp certification is the
beginning of your journey as a project
management expert but it certainly
doesn't end there it is a continuous
learning cycle so here in this webinar
tim's going to talk with you about the
essential pieces that will make sure you
don't just retain your pmp certification
by earning your pdos pdus but also
continue to gain additional skills that
you need the most to remain competitive
this webinar is a an amalgamation of
years of research based on responses by
thousands of professionals and tim's
going to share his wisdom with you
so
if you're not familiar with who tim
jerome is let me bring you up to speed
he is a project manager trainer and
mentor
a pmp prep instructor a consultant and
an advisor with tj consulting he's got
extensive expertise in multiple
industries embracing business and
financial analysis as well as
non-technical project management he
spent 12 years with intel as a technical
engineer a project manager a consulting
project manager
a business analyst a program manager a
marketing engineer he taught intro to
project management and pmp prep courses
and assisted fortune 50 companies in
adopting bleeding edge technologies for
operational efficiency
improved productivity and a competitive
edge
so we are very fortunate to have tim
here and i'm looking forward to hearing
what he has to say but before we get
started i just want to make sure
everybody's hearing us okay so take a
look at your dashboards real quick folks
and find the questions module you will
see a place for you to type in questions
for
tim and myself
so please go ahead and find that module
and just type a quick hello in there
just say hi to tim let him know that
you're excited to have him here and
you're looking forward to
learning uh what it's going to take oh
my gosh i see all kinds of people saying
hello there so that's good to know hi
raj harriet deanna rajiv
travis
nathan watson lots of folks from all
over the place i'm sure
happy to have tim on board so that's
great to know that you can hear me pay
attention to that questions module that
will be your best friend as we're going
through the presentation type your
questions in ask for an additional
clarification maybe tim needs to scroll
back and look at a previous slide uh
what have you uh if possible he'll field
your question uh right there real time
if it's appropriate otherwise we will
loop back around at the end of the
presentation and make sure that we go
through the q a and address as many
uh as many of your questions as we
possibly can if while we're going you
want to share what you're learning on
your social platforms by all means feel
free to do so if you uh if you hear a
particular little nugget of wisdom and
you want to put it in the form of 140
characters or more now with twitter go
ahead and do so and use the hashtag sl
webinars let folks know what you're
learning make them jealous that they're
not here with you maybe they'll join us
next time
with all of that said without any
further ado please do go ahead and sit
back grab a cup of coffee or a cup of
chai or a glass of wine if it's that
time of the evening for you sit back
take a few notes and mr jerome is here
to
lay down the wisdom hi tim thanks for
joining us
hi chip and thanks so much for the
introduction
uh this is great um welcome everyone uh
welcome to those of you who have been my
students i notice a few names out there
um welcome also to uh all of you guys
who are
um here interested in uh finding out
what i have to talk about i had a mentor
when i was
just about to get my pmp and he and i
used to talk about two things all the
time first of all we outsourced a lot of
our project management in our in our
corporation and he and i used to talk
about what does a twenty dollar an hour
project manager do what does a fifty or
a seventy five dollar an hour if a
project manager is billable at a hundred
and fifty dollars an hour what's their
job like what do i have to do to be able
to get that
that started the discussion then we went
on and said okay
what is a five-year project manager what
does a 10-year project manager do if
you're a project manager for 20 and 25
years and i personally have known a
30-year project manager actually two or
three of them
um
how did they get there what did they do
what is it that actually makes them that
that's successful that's part of what
we're going to answer today
again
as i go through here we'll get a lot of
questions i want to make sure that we
cover this in a way that is not just a
good story and leads you in a direction
but also gives you
actions that you can take to determine
your path we're going to learn that our
skills that we've learned as project
managers are the very skills that are
going to continue to make us successful
so today
we're going to talk about a few things
oh how do i get a copy of the slides um
and i always get this
check with simply learn
um uh um
simply learn usually um has a pdf
version of these slides and they will
provide a link and it's usually up in
youtube as well
um
these are these are developed for them
so they own the content but uh yeah
check with them after the uh recording
and see uh see how you can get a copy
um
uh just a second here
us
and youtube and
uh
on
simplylearn.com there we go
that's good answer thanks guys for your
interest
um so today real quickly we're going to
talk
about we're going to baseline on uh
project management and what a average
project manager does and what they think
about um then we're going to talk about
personal development career planning i
work locally here as a mentor advisor to
groups organizations companies and
individuals as a mentor how do i set a
plan or course for the next part of my
career in my life we'll talk about that
um how to climb the ladder and how a
project manager naturally develops
professionally we don't want to develop
naturally we want to go in the direction
we want to go
also
how are skills
you know as they're reflected in the pmp
prep material how they are really good
to
not just help us
become very good at our jobs but open up
opportunities
there are some things that have been
happening for the last five to ten years
and actually there's like late breaking
information that's really interesting
and we're going to talk about how this
changes
our opportunities as well as our our
position in business and then of course
i always leave time for a call to action
and the direction we're going to go
this is this is your book to write
you've just finished the chapter if
you've gained your pmp now what do you
do from there
that
i'm going to give you some opportunities
in
okay let's see here
so
um
i as most project managers accidentally
became a project manager i was good i
was consistent i was detailed yet i
understood
why we were doing the work and that
seemed to work really well with the
people that were giving me work
at the same time in the 1992s and
through 1995
teams were just becoming important there
was formal training in teams and not
only that but they were talking about
these these clumps of work that you're
unique and time-bound how do you make
that happen
um
so it the
it was just like coming together for me
as i was progressing though and getting
my pmp i did that in 2003 i found out
um that
everybody around me woke up one day and
they were project managers there wasn't
really a job title except in real big
corporations that said you're a project
manager and there wasn't a career path
or anything so i learned very
very early one fact
if i didn't plan my career
nobody else did it for me
so i started looking at that i went to i
looked at formal education and training
and i took all the training my company
could provide in everything i was very
very busy i was i was studying early
morning and late at night but at the
same time i was learning three major
categories of skills
first of all project management
general technical skills how do you
monitor and control work series today on
schedule how do you monitor and control
work
so you can stay within budget
and how do you do it so that you can say
i did the work the right way and i
completed it
so that that was part of what we were
looking at those are all those are our
baselines right scope cost and schedule
but there's so much more
leadership
had to come in play and that's one of
the reasons why i doubled down on
management and how people lead
this is uh and this this is critical
because
we have a decision when we first start
as project managers number one
we can totally control the environment
iron fist right that this is the way
things are going to go and that's it
we can do things that way and some of us
are very successful however
on the other hand there's another way
that i learned it takes longer and it
takes a much more broad and mature skill
set where we relinquish a little control
and we supplement that control with
something called trust and with trust
and with transparency and communication
i learned that all of a sudden i was
getting commitment and investment from
the people around me i was living and
breathing what i had studied and what
all these people for the last 200 years
have been saying
this made sense to me and it got
exciting
now at the same time
i was doing these this work in a vacuum
and i realized there was another
component i had to learn
it's called business
you know that
we're talking much more of that inside
of project management institute about
business and business skills and without
us connecting our work
to
the business objective there's no reason
for us to move forward i've seen corp uh
inside corporations
business units basically go away because
they no longer fulfilled a business need
so we have to have all three of these
skills
project management leadership and
business business acumen sometimes
called we have to have that directly in
place
now
what's nice
is all of these fulfill the needs of
doing and and managing uh projects
successfully however they go much
further
you can get the gist of what i'm talking
about right
any company will willingly
support you if you're willing to get if
you can get work done
in time on budget and according to the
way they ask you that's how you keep
your job
and they're willing to double down on
investing in you if you understand how
your work connects to the business
and how uh work uh and and if you can
actually
manage teams i have a question here
let's see
um let's see here just a second
uh praveen
if you want to uh just send a question
through your q a console and i'll be
happy to answer it
let's see here and and that's the key
right here all of these skills don't
just apply to managing projects
successfully they're managing business
successfully we have an opportunity
through project management to to
introduce ourselves as successful
participants in generating revenue for
the company that is the big message okay
project management is now being seen as
that entry point no longer does uh does
a corporation you know hit
certain employees with the magic manager
wand and take them through management
training no
we build ourselves and we introduce
ourselves there we go i got a chat
question
oh thanks chip
okay so
so here we are
now
we know that we have it how can we
actually get really deep in in this
knowledge how did tim do it how did
these other people who were successful
in project management 15 20 and 30 years
do it how did they get their starts
well this is what all of my mentors told
me
it's sort of like uh in alice in
wonderland where alice asks the cheshire
cat
um should i go left or right
and uh
and the cheshire cat says well
do you have a goal in mind if not it
doesn't matter
without a goal
you don't get where you want
and guess who has all this formal
training
for hitting goals and business
objectives
we already have the skills we need to
hit exactly what we want
do i think project manager for a
technology company must have technical
knowledge great ass uh question
something i'll talk a little bit more
about that but generally
um
there's there's opportunity what i would
say is
are you really interested in that
technical knowledge what's gonna happen
is
by investing time
um even in information technology areas
by investing time you're committing
yourself to a direction
keep that in mind we we are not just
thinking about do i want to be this but
we have to think about the fact that we
are going to be progressing and we're
we're basically committing not just i i
i'm not i don't care about committing
money but my time and my interest do i
want to do this type of work for the
next five or ten years you don't have to
um there's a broad there's there's so
much opportunity for general project
managers and and we'll look at the
numbers here in a bit
it really depends
now i i do want to state
not only
the product it's not only that project
management skills work well to help you
but
we've actually we've actually
built profit for companies why should we
not profit over the skills
and actually invest in ourselves
this is this is the message we all get
this in my intro to introduction to
project management courses it's a common
discussion over lunch to say you know
these skills are great they help me plan
my vacations they help me plan my
college ever you know and i'm actually
able to determine the potential uh value
and this we get this naturally you know
we're genetically predisposed
to project management we get this but we
need to articulate it to ourselves
sometimes
and and this is the key guys
when you're in career planning
it's not just a project anymore you need
to consider
career planning under portfolio
management it's something that you
actively manage
through through your life that's how you
keep your career healthy and progressing
in the direction you want and and like i
said before a tech going down the
technology path is great
if you are passionate about that
technology and have some deep connection
to it because you're going to be doing
it for a while
cleaning up my board
now
here's how you do it
there's a
there's a um a bullet on the bottom of
this page you may or may not be able to
see it from here um the the article is
managing oneself if you know drucker
he's an efficiency expert peter drucker
right and he talked about um the fact
this and and this is
i'm gonna jump out of the uh
presentation here for a minute because
this is important
um
so drucker said some things and this is
back in 1999 okay
and this is on careers
and career management
he was no longer talking about business
and company efficiency he said
we can expect
to have
some type of work
you know how many years he said back in
1999 we can expect to be working for up
to 50 years
isn't that amazing we you know we think
about people having jobs for 30 years or
40 years to be phenomenal you know being
in the workforce and peter was saying
up to 50 years he was looking at the
longevity of people and the direction
people's interest in their careers was
going
and that's the key if you want to work
for 50 years you better really enjoy
what you're doing project management
establishes early on a foundation a
fundamental base that opens you up for a
lot of opportunities so it's it's
actually one of the areas that actually
can can start off this 50 years of
investment i'm not talking about going
into an office for 50 years okay
new no new i'm talking more about
staying engaged in giving back to a
community being a volunteer being active
and what drucker said is to increase the
value that we
get from our investment the return on
investment for for our careers
um
we have to do it knowledgeably
we have to we have to actively manage
and actively control our path and he
said
it's easy for the first 20 years okay
it's going to be really easy all you
have to do is make companies happy if
you if
and you you go to a university you find
a foundation a skill set much like
project management and you develop those
skills you're going to be strong in some
areas and you're going to be weak in
other areas okay and you and for the
first for the first 20 years guess what
you do
you strengthen
your weaknesses okay
now this is where it gets interesting
you're going to switch careers it
happens about between the 40s and 50s
look at me you know 2012 a corporation
said goodbye tim what was i to do peter
drucker spoke directly to me and peter
said tim this is what you do
play to your strengths you have the
first career
the first job in your career your next
job in your career do something that
you're really good at and that you can
really get involved in for a long term
what did i choose
i choose to be with you people it it
it keeps me alive and active it keeps me
participating in work that i find
engaging and this is what peter said is
needed right there
find that for the first 20 years just
just build yourself get well-rounded and
then you play to your strengths
he actually developed something called
feedback analysis
now this is the key right here
he said every six months evaluate
yourself don't do it any sooner than
that not day to day not month month
every six months change one thing
when he said improve your strengths
change one thing every six months don't
change anything else because if you do a
lot of changes you don't know what's
valuable
it's slow we don't like slow okay we
like fast and getting things out of the
way but drucker said this you have to
carefully manage this
and there's another
there's another risk
okay
we are brilliant people
we are bright we are smart
however
as a project manager
we are hammers
and
the world looks like a nail when you're
a hammer
and peter drucker said wait
you must always be looking
for those areas don't ignore your
weaknesses because you'll be putting
stuff
in the back burner that could create a
risk for you he he doesn't say ignore
your weaknesses but he says focus on
your strengths
the
the risk of taking this path he said
is
making sure that you do the appropriate
risk management on where you don't look
i'm a great i'm i'm great with looking
at the big picture i'm
really lousy with detail oriented so my
advisors are always detail oriented
advisors and that's how i balance this
out
but drucker said this is the way
corporations become very
very successful
he says this is the long game
this is the long game for not just uh
creating you know a 75 dollar to a
hundred dollar an hour job but it's uh
for for satisfaction in life
an unanalyzed life is an opportunity for
somebody else to control your direction
and if you're not in control you will
not find satisfaction
now i am going to go into what this
means for us as project managers now
before i do let's do a really quick
review
when you studied your for your pmp or if
you went to business school
you remember um
we talked about the deming short cycle
okay
plan do check act right
let's do a quick review of that
i want to make sure
that we all understand that the nuances
of that okay
in my classes i am adamant to talk about
this we don't in plan just determine
what we're going to do
we also predict
or estimate the result what's going to
happen this is critical because we want
to get better at plan do check act as
well as everything else so we do next
and then
in check what do we do
we confirm to action taken
and
results
are as expected see how we're building
in that's the validation right in in our
change in change management change
control we always need to validate our
changes not just that they occurred but
the results are as expected so dimming
in short said
in act
we're able to make the change permanent
or back out right
very simple very fundamental but very
powerful we're we're okay with this and
this is how we're going to make
incremental changes we look at our
strengths how can they open up
opportunities how can they get deeper in
our opportunities this is going to
foreshad this is going to
be
um be
integrated throughout the rest of our
discussion
so
first five years
you've done it
years um we're all experts and we are
all peers i i i neglected and i
apologize i always start off with that i
am not
on a huge um podium talking down to you
we're in a room um we could very well be
talking about this after dinner over
dessert and i love those kind of
conversations this is where we are
we have basically achieved expertise
with three to five years of successful
project management and by gaining a
credential
we have a foundation but just like
martial arts that's just the first step
this just gets us to where we can
actually explore beyond what we do day
to day
that's what we do
year five to ten and this is where the
real world certifications and our cross
knowledge area development comes in this
is what do i want to do
in my ex in my personal experience and
you need to be asking this in my
personal experience what is the most
viable option
is it exploring technology
certifications is it information
technology should i go into business
process improvement or financial
analysis which one opens up the greatest
opportunities you need to be collecting
the data analyzing and estimating across
that in year 5 to 10. this is important
because
through your research analysis and
improving
in year 10 and above you become what's
called a
specialist generalist okay basically you
are not just an expert but you have
mastered your fundamentals
and
you have deep skills in one of a few
areas this is where you have an
opportunity
okay
at this fork in the road you can
actually make a huge jump in promotion
or you can make a lateral transfer
inside your company or industry or even
outside your industry you have a lot of
options
those options look really interesting
business management
do you want to go be you want to go into
general business you have the skills for
it now
do you want to focus in technology have
you been doing technology projects have
you been building these general
certifications in technology that
actually give you
um a little edge over other potential
project managers or
do you want to focus
in projects or types of projects like me
i uh
within about three years of being a
professional consultant
there was an opportunity to open up in
data centers and helping corporations
transition through centralizing and
standardizing their approach to data and
applications these are easily 100 to 300
million dollar projects do you want to
get into that class a project you can
now you don't do it just by saying i
want to
you do it
way back here
in doing your research and analysis
what is interesting to me what's
interesting to the industry what's
interesting to my corporation is there
anything there that i would
would want to pursue for the next 15 to
20 years
ah now we can see how the program and
portfolio are fitting in with our plan
right it goes even further
i can look in in general business
project management going at the program
level or looking at uh business analysis
now i'm quoting a lot of pmi credentials
here okay it doesn't have to be this way
it the credentials you are looking for
are the ones that you are going to be
valuable now we're going to see
something interesting here in a few
minutes
but for that
how about six sigma lean agile these are
how i do work inside of companies six
sigma improvement
incremental improvement as well as
initiating and maintaining levels of
quality
yep there is a lot of opportunity there
and with that type of credential in fact
one of my friends is constantly pulled
across the united states on a regular
basis in fact about eight to ten of my
peers here locally work outside of the
state almost all year based on this how
do we help businesses make change this
is how six sigma lean agile a
programmatic approach business analysis
making changes not just through projects
and implementation
but helping the transition through
decision making
and that's the key right there
you have a choice
do you want to stay general
or
if you started off technical do you want
to stay technical you have a choice
however
midway through
you need to start
uh um minimizing
your options there's too many options we
have
such uh such a grasp on so many general
skills that you do need to focus and
drucker says let's focus on our
strengths what are you having fun with
what are you good at
do you want to go into a pmo
pmos are great for people who have about
10 years of successful project
experience especially deep
broad very complex projects they
understand how projects interact at the
program level and they're very diligent
outside of the project for controls and
management right archiving centralizing
standardizing their organizational
process assets now
it gets really interesting because there
are other credentials that actually
complement what we do
the i.t information library started off
in europe
this is this is something that every
corporation that runs a formal
information technology environment
understands
um cmmi
quality right quality in how i do my
information technology organization work
i got a question here just second let me
clean up my
screen and i'll answer it
deanna yeah
i i tell you guys thanks for that
comment deanna um
i'm gonna send this out to everybody
because i have to i have to say that we
are genetically predisposed we are a
group
look for people
look for peers um the most important
thing about projects and project
management is we don't spend enough time
around each other
the the the the important thing is guys
that
we are not crazy we're the voice of
reason that's why companies like us at
the same time we need to be speaking to
ourselves and seeing where we need to go
um
and and then the question is
what would i recommend in your situation
oh that's easy um that's really easy um
we'll talk about that uh
basically here you are great generalist
what are you interested in
what are you really interested in that's
the key
um
we'll talk more about that in a little
bit sometimes mix of the skills are
needed because project man remember um
and vikesh
and this is really important um
uh var uh varsha um
varsha says i've noticed sometimes a mix
of the skills are needed because project
management do need estimation skills and
in order to perform correct estimation
technical skills are also necessary
exactly
this is the key the the problem is we
are so general and
we have to learn how to use those
general skills in very specific areas we
have a choice we can become deeply
technical
or
become even
more deep
um
deeply general
and this is cool okay what do i mean by
this
well
we can become highly technical so we
become subject matter experts or we can
become really strong in leadership
so that we know how to bring everybody
to the table that's the key
you have a choice
do you want to become deeply technical
you can make a lot of money that way and
be really satisfied that's what we're
looking for or
you can get really good at staying
general but really double down on your
leadership and you get really good at
bringing people together you know the
we talk about this charisma and charm
the people who walk in and you know
everything's going to be all right you
have the opportunity to stay general if
you acknowledge it and understand how to
bring the smart and wise people to the
table and have all voices heard
facilitate the best solution
guys we do this all the time you have a
choice
now
let's let's move on um this is really
interesting okay
and the data that we're looking at here
actually looks at what what do we want
to do
do we want to stay general
i in the united states staying general
is not a bad thing right
and that that doesn't take us too far
out of our skill set you know think
about this correlation
to um
to
our general skill set
that's interesting isn't it now we can
go into business process improvement
quality management
we can actually look at support
tools and support roles itil doesn't
just apply to
information technology you can take the
process flows in itil and put it into
any business process and agile applies
not just in software but manufacturing
production anywhere
there is an opportunity here you don't
have to stop anywhere it has to do with
your satisfaction
and and again from a managed services
standpoint this this is becoming really
interesting because microsoft is just
talking about uh data science and
managed services these are all very
general but
there is great
opportunity here
and that's that's the beauty of our
positions in our careers
now it means that we're going to be
continuing to work right
yes and we're going to have to continue
to develop ourselves and we're going to
have to manage our careers for our lives
but on the other hand look at where
we're going
and that's where simply learn comes in
right
do all these things look familiar they
should
we've actually seen this happening and
we've been developing this for a while
we understand that your career
planning and your career management is
not just in one place it's a lifetime
approach you're going to see more and
more of this as we go further
let's see i got another question
oh sure oh what's the difference between
pmp and prince2
um they're both project management
credentials
uh
but but
quickly
pmp
establishes a certain level
of uh expertise right here i am three to
five years prince actually has a
graduated um pmi has a capm credential
there's a first level of prince that
looks at it what that looks at that how
do you how do you get somebody
introduced to how projects work and how
do you get them into
the education path it works sort of like
capm
the first level of prints now they have
second third and fourth level of prints
too prince and the prince2 structure for
project management credentialing
happened in europe
at the same time the pmp credential
emerged out of project management
institute through the 60s 70s 80s and
90s in the united states they're both
um they're they're both aligned with the
same iso project management standards so
you can think of them pretty much as
equivalent it's just corporations
basically commit to one framework or the
other and that's where you see
preference uh company to company in the
united states you can assume that pmp is
there in the europe and in some other
nations over there globally you'll see
prints too
this
is a home run for many people okay
you don't just have
project management expertise but you
have expertise in managing and
initiating change
perfect
and with itil on top of that
that puts you in line
with exerting your management skills and
expertise in information technology if
you want to remain there
if you want to remain there this is a
great opportunity
now
it goes even further
we've we've seen a movement um not just
into um
six sigma but lean
lean is actually six sigma with
efficiency integrated in
and and we see this a lot
and and other forms of agile and agile
service management
we see
this
we can let's let's define agile real
quickly
agile is a methodology or an approach to
work project and operations
that
responds to change
ambiguity
volatility
and that's that's what i mean when i say
agile by
adding this to our skill set mix
we're we're smoke jumpers now we know
business we're leaders we we have a
a
very definite way of doing work and we
can manage in the middle of chaos
see it we have these opportunities and
this
and actually learning and integrating
agile in the way we do work opens up
things it doesn't commit us to a path it
opens up to multiple opportunities i can
use agile now in all my work even my
personal life
cool
now
what do we have to play with
when i said technical skills
this is what i looked at
right
accurate estimation predictable controls
guaranteed results were
not just
accurate but were precise right we're
able to repeat success
remember that that's going to be
important
does
acp replace lean six sigma and uh agile
sir uh not necessarily not necessarily
the agile certification is integrated in
with the project management framework as
defined in the pmbok okay think about it
that way
and agile is with that certification
it's a methodology that you become that
you basically publicly declare yourself
to be expert in
it's a component
and agile as as you develop
and prepare for your acp looks at not
just uh introducing agility into your
project work but also your operations
work when we talk about lean six sigma
plus
um agile service management we're
talking about a broader range of skill
sets they're all there generally in the
pmp
what and and that's what we have to
remember at a fundamental level we know
lean
we actually know six sigma in quality
management six sigma is integrated into
our fundamental knowledge now acp takes
us
deeper into one path agile does not talk
to the value of lean
efficiency as deep as lean six sigma
does
and it doesn't have the specific um
steps now if you're if you're choosing
between acp and lean six sigma plus asm
do your research find out uh talk to
your companies who are offering jobs and
ask the recruiters
um what what credentials does this
industry or this company um uh recommend
what are they looking for
and
often this will actually help you
determine more the and and guys it
sounds a little pragmatic here but this
is the way you manage and maintain your
direction
i i would not put acp above asm itself
either i would look myself at the
industry and see which one i'd recommend
at my point in my life i go with agile
certification because i'm more committed
down the path of the pembox frame of
project management
lean six sigma actually exposes you to
business and operations though um
varsha you're right the agile
certification is just getting
getting
adoption
the asm has been there for a while
you're right
and again that you see we're we're
actually able to say those things
because we're doing research and
analysis look and don't just look at the
numbers of people who have gotten it but
but look at it primarily from you know
what what what's the value proposition
that's the key okay what is it
i i hate to say this but what's in it
for me you know what what does this mean
to me how does it translate to value
will it make me more satisfied will it
gain me more opportunities in these days
we can expect two to three years of
being stable in in an organization and
either that organization's going to
change radically or the company's going
to change radically and we must stay
very flexible
hey there's that change right
project management skills um
and let's make sure that we understand
these business skills right
we're able to
connect
our work to business value why am i
doing this this is because
why do i want agile
because this is the value
this is the value and
the
it's going to be hard to get these
certifications it's just as hard as
getting others right it's going to take
time and investment you're not going to
have a lot of fun but
by
actually aligning to this business
objective guess what you're applying
theory x uchi right
motivation is alignment to the big
picture
i'm connecting myself to a vision
this is key
right here
connecting yourself to the vision in
your career
you already have these skills
decision making i would recommend five
ten years make sure you understand do
your research
look at traditional decision making and
then look at how your company makes
decision is there a formal process in
companies that are older than 75 years
guess what
they they these these people have
actually gone away from do i manufacture
according to production or do i do a
software model no
all of their project life cycles are
based on how the company generally makes
decisions
look at that look at that and also this
is the key and this is the primary
reason this bottom area proven growth
why you need to continue to grow and
invest in your business skills
success
business is all again all about
um
[Music]
amplifying success and and making
success more prevalent
let's see here just real quickly
um i got a hand raise um if you want to
please uh please uh send your questions
in chat and i'll be able to integrate
them in i it looks like i will have a
little time i need to go a little faster
here guys so i can complete the material
and open it up for general questions but
please ask your questions as i'm as i'm
going through here
let's see here
yeah i'm getting too excited about this
um
motivation you're going to need like i
said i talked already about motivation
uh conflict resolution even with
yourself is going to be important and
increased performance
all of these
are amplified when you apply it to
yourself because guess what you're
getting all the benefit of the value of
the investment
yeah
and you're going to need to
as drucker and deming say continually
improve this as well as
continue to improve the skills that are
marketable
invest
now this is this is what's key i i do
want to talk about this for a couple
minutes okay um career planning has
actually uh changed inside of the
project management institute and they
focused
formal training and pdus
along technical business and leadership
topics that's basically why i broke the
conversation down into those three areas
today
great if you have questions send it to
me uh send it to me in chat and i'll try
to bring it in um i will
we will have an open discussion here
after we're through
um i see hand hands raised if if you
have questions please
send them in chat
now the needs and the opportunities for
you personally investing in
um your your development uh you have the
foundation it just gets better more
investment is
is like
geometrically or astronomically greater
in return if as you continue to invest
and like like drucker said this is not
just for 20 years you have to think
about
the value you can do this across 50
years
so in wrap-up
what do you want to do
right there
make it a conscious written formal
document
have your plan what do i need to do now
what do i need to do in three years what
do i want
in five years use deming's plan to check
act and use drucker's model
playing to your strengths and then
maximizing those results but don't
ignore your weaknesses
next
build your in infrastructure and this is
five to ten years you're a broad
generalist expert deep skills embark on
crazy deep skills endeavor to don't be
the world's best return on investment
expert be better than you were yesterday
and you won't have any competitors okay
crazy deep is where you want to start
investing in for for 10 years and above
and then like i said like we've been
saying go back collect your data analyze
deming says it all plan do check act and
and do it consciously guys and just like
in our projects we add
where where it's going to make the
project successful
and we also add where it keeps our work
from failure
okay we are here together um i've had a
wonderful ride here with simply learn
and it's going to last the rest of my
life
the way things are going now they they
have gone so far and you'll see what
i've been talking about reflected in
their offerings right and these
offerings are not just for introductory
they're for refinement of our skills as
we continue and and to that fact we've
actually
we've actually focused on what we call a
master class program this isn't just
introduction anymore and this isn't just
mid-level this is a community of experts
that are looking at how do i add to
become not just an expert but a master
and how it integrates in
with the rest of my skill sets we do
have a project management
group
and of of uh offerings and if you don't
see what you're interested in please
tell us but you can understand how
project management can be reflected in
all of these areas i see i still have
hands raised i apologize
that's my material
at this point
i'm more than happy to invite questions
let's see here i don't know if we can do
open mic we have over 50 people and i
want to get to as many questions as
possible is there a way that you can
send your questions through q a please
hey tim that's uh this is chip
terrific presentation thank you yes
please folks uh
you have access to both a questions
module and a chat module preferably use
the questions module if you could it
makes it a little easier for the admins
on this side to keep track of who's
asking what and
and keep things organized the other
thing i'm going to do really quickly
is check the chat module everybody
really quickly i am going to
share some links with you
these aren't all the available links but
these are a few of the links to get you
started in
pardon me seeing
what courses are available for you over
on the simply learn site so you'll see
some links to a variety of simply
learned courses uh the master's courses
that tim mentioned as well as
some specific pmp courses and some
related
skill sets
also a link to pmi.org if you're not
familiar with that and a couple of
articles in our other upcoming webinars
that we have queued up into the future
please feel free to take a look at
those as well
all of that said uh fantastic tim thank
you so much now i'm looking at the
questions module
and um
tim i'll let you take a look at that and
pick and choose which questions you'd
like to respond directly to i see a few
coming in from khalil james citacar
yes and i i want to speak um pdus real
quickly okay um um
so we know we know we need to claim pdus
how do i get pdus for this session
you can claim it
um
uh
uh through my pmi um those of you who
have uh pmps you know how to do that
this will be a technical
pm
uh credential for presentation um it's
the it has to be you have to select
technical leadership or
or business and this is more technical
than anything else we're talking about
very specific actions to take
we have a lot of leadership in this
discussion as well
you claim it remember pmi is a community
of trust
if you have issues or if they ask you
for an audit
please
please point them to the presentation or
you you can use other validation through
simply learn on that
let's see here how do you get pdus any
format available
um if that's a general question for
those of you who have not
attained pdus or not uh you've not
captured or documented any pdus up on
the pmi website um i don't think i'm
logged in right now under me my pmi
um this is where you um
this is where you
um submit your pdus and within three to
five business days they accept them and
they're documented for you there's a
when you get into this module and when
you get your pmp or other uh pmi
credentials
they'll actually um
they'll actually
tell you how to do it the specific steps
it changes from time to time and in fact
changed
uh just about four days ago the whole uh
website changed um
so let's see here sudakar you say if a
certified pmp is working in
manufacturing is it possible to get
employed in it finance yes oh yes oh yes
oh yes uh sudakar um
um here's
here's how i did it okay i was in
manufacturing right but what happened
was
um they asked me a couple questions
about finance and i said sure i know
this i took some business classes no i i
got my graduate degree in in business
administration
but at the same time i made really good
friends in finance and accounting and i
found out how various organizations
connected with finance and accounting
guys think about it this way okay
this is this is the way i want you to
think about career planning right here
you are
career planning is not that
it's not that at all career planning is
like this
you're looking at parallel trajectories
so this is going to be of your biggest
interest
like you with manufacturing finance and
accounting find those points where you
can actually exhibit skills and you can
integrate further in with the
organization that you're interested in
this this
this is done more and more informally
inside of corporations there's not a lot
of formal support the corporations
provide that's one of the reasons why
i'm preventing here i'm presenting
because we don't see support for this
yeah look at it look at it as a as a
gradual transition over one to three
years and you'll find opportunities to
meet the right people find mentors as
well as find the connections between
your your hopefully future position and
your current position
next question is let's see here
yeah i'm hopping back and forth between
a lot of things
let's see here
oh
is there any pre-work experience for the
certifications for pmp and prince2 with
pmp you need three to five years of not
project management you need three to
five years of directing and managing
project work that means that you led
interviews that means that you managed
or you did the plan
or you
managed the
test lab okay you led and directed
project activities that's the pmp now
for prince2 the first level you don't
need anything
for the second through the fourth level
you have varying degrees of requirements
for work experience it's very similar to
project and project management because
project management is so informal in
many companies
we can't say that you had to have
the um
job description of project manager for
three years it doesn't work that way
let's see more questions
i i i'm glad i'm glad you're finding
value in this guys
and and for those of you who are
continuing with uh
simply learn let's not
stop the conversation those of you who
are currently have active accounts with
simply learn i can be found over in the
discussion section in the forums um and
and stay in touch with me ask questions
this is what we're here for all of us
project management trainers we've been
doing this and we we want you to learn
from our failures both in projects as
well as in our careers
um we're here and and whether or not you
stay in touch with me build your
community you're we're we're alone we're
lone um
leaders a lot of times and we need to
stay connected just to maintain uh
sanity
uh more questions let's see here yeah i
noticed uh chip thanks for putting up
the
uh future uh future uh webinars as well
as the articles um and and i do want to
thank prasant
um there's a great article that he
that he actually contributed to this
this latter here
came from
i'm sorry himach deshpond
you can find this on the public website
he talks about it from an
i.t perspective
and i took my experience plus his i.t
discussion to actually build this out
okay
by the way my experience includes about
four or five mentors who at the time had
20 to 30 years of experience
so you're getting multi-generational
wisdom here guys
if this is not tim wisdom this is
project manager wisdom
hey tim i've got a question for you that
hopefully will be valuable to everybody
when you talk about uh creating uh you
know your community and interacting with
your peers of course on the simply
learned site in the uh
in the forums and so forth in the
discussion areas that's a great place to
do that
are there
any other sort of
specific industry conferences or blogs
or organizations that you would
recommend for folks to keep on top of
project management trends maybe specific
linkedin groups that you might recommend
where you see people really getting some
valuable interactions
and also on that note
uh if you had to pick the top two or
three
publications or blogs that you follow on
a regular basis what might those be
oh good one good one thanks chip
so of course because i have a pmp i
align myself with the project management
institute and that's where i look at
most of the research they have like two
three decades of research that is you
know of the level and quality of gartner
and forester i've been using their data
for years in my research and analysis as
well as public presentation and that's
really good stuff
they own a website and i'll get to i'll
get to the next question just second
project management.com
is a public community okay one of the
things that i did not get to talk about
today
was this topic and it just came up
is there an opportunity for me to become
an independent contractor yes many
corporations are
and what does that mean for me well
this guy andy says two things okay he
says it means great opportunity for us
to become generalist but we're isolated
from the business part of projects and
so for us to maintain that we have to
become
very good at building in the subject
matter experts who can help us keep our
work integrated in projectmanagement.com
has white papers it has a lot of the
functions and capabilities of
linkedin
yet it also caters to the project
management career
with linkedin i would advise you to look
at the
project management communities look how
many um
participants there are not just once but
month to month to see which ones are
healthy and which ones are are stagnant
um i'm not going to recommend any i only
belong to four or five
i find i find the
the greater interaction happening
at different in different areas but it's
a great place to build a
build a network of peer support across
corporations and industries so project
management naturally gravitates to
linkedin
i can't really think about any specific
group that's the best
let's see here
those are the big ones
um professional development one of the
reasons why i like uh pmi so much is
they have a they're driven not just to
supporting you now but supporting you
for the next two or three decades of
your career
and it and it has a lot to do with
giving back to the community
i notice also that i'm getting some
hands raised do i have more check
more questions in q a
um i'm showing the q a is all caught up
if anybody does have any additional last
minute questions go ahead and use the
questions module and type it in there
and that way
tim and myself will be able to see it
and we'll make sure that it gets
responded to in the meantime you're
talking about linkedin real briefly
there tim maybe we can address one other
thing as folks are developing their uh
their professional
presentation and in particular on
linkedin
aside from adding the certifications
that they've developed to their profile
do you have any other advice about how
to present yourself well on linkedin do
you list specific projects that you've
managed or would you do you think it's
more appropriate to list business names
and industries that you work in as
opposed to specific projects what's the
best way to present yourself there to to
do yourself a favor
thanks so much chip a lot of our
projects
we can't divulge a lot of information
so we want to have a general approach
but
we want to connect to as many decision
makers in the work environment that we
have to basically that's the validation
of our success right
so we want to have a path now getting
back to the whole history and what i did
um it's critical that us as project
managers have not just a resume
we need a portfolio you know just like
just like people in the movies and in
advertising industries this is my work
we need to create this i'm talking about
this all the time in career development
have our portfolio
the projects this the stuff that you can
share um you know basically within your
and not break any nda but it lists your
success and not just from i did this
project successfully but what was the
business impact and and we need to as uh
project managers think that you know we
we need not just a resume but we need a
portfolio projects and programs and
portfolios that that show our impact to
business now in linkedin the way we do
that is how we connect to individuals
and
once we have this broad network we need
to start talking as experts once you
have a pmp guess what you are an expert
in fact let me see here
a lot of a lot of my
former students you'll see their
pictures on the top here um i'm looking
for one who spoke in europe just about
about two weeks ago on uh
internet of things and security uh
brilliant uh presentation um
[Music]
market yourself don't be you know don't
be uh
don't be
huge in marketing but don't be afraid to
tell what your value is and your value
is your benefit back to
you know the work you did
what how meaningful it was think about a
grandpa taking a kid to a dam that the
grandpa built 40 years ago and he says
see that brick there that's me
that's what we should be doing both in
linkedin and our resumes and portfolios
building your personal brand is huge and
i i believe that uh on simply learn
certainly on market mode of the
the sister company uh there are some uh
video lessons and courses on building
personal brands so definitely great
kartik has a question here and uh we're
over by about 12 minutes now and i so
it's the last question i see in the
questions module so maybe this is a good
way to to end things is asking what is
the current
pmbok edition
and will there be any new revisions or
changes in the near future
oh
you actually can participate in it right
now critique
if you want to you can go on to pmi
right now and they have the future
edition 6 edition up for review it's
going to be there through the end of the
month and
just go it's open to the public not just
active members of pmi
um it's going to be
released in production the end of 2017
it's talking a lot more about agile
because companies want us
to uh react to change more they don't
like it
we understand um as pmps we understand
that the pmbok is you know primarily
there not just for control but for
change as well but companies are asking
more and more about agile and agile
methodologies and an agile approach not
just for change but for ambiguity and so
it's being talked much more in there
read it go in there and and if you have
some input please by all means
contribute your wisdom
perfect
i think that's probably it i don't see
any other questions unless you're seeing
any uh questions coming to you through
chat i can't see those if they're
directed directly to you but i think
that's it for the questions in the
questions module i do want to make one
comment you mentioned specialist
generalist which i love as a phrase in
digital marketing for the last five
years or so we've referred to what we
call
t-shaped marketers and maybe t-shaped is
also used in other industries as well
but it's the same idea it's those
marketers who have a broad foundational
knowledge across all the critical
disciplines but then deep expertise in
one or two marketing specialties so i've
seen that kind of thing referred to as
t-shaped professional uh and specialist
generalist is
another way of referencing it but it's
it's interesting to see that that's a uh
that's a trend across industries to
you know to to have a good broad
foundation of all kinds of aspects of
the business and the skill sets and then
really
focus on your specialties where you feel
like you're the strongest
excellent thanks so much for that input
chip
absolutely well listen uh i think uh
critique you're welcome uh
and all of you tim if you've got
anything else to add as a closing
comment
i am good um thank you guys thanks chip
and simply learn and thanks for
everybody else again we're all peers
here um we invite your comments we
invite your input
and i'm just pleased that this resonated
with at least a few of you
absolutely well it was fun for me and
it's been a long time since i worked in
project management and i'm not a pmp by
the way i'll make that very clear
back in 2001 when i was managing web
development projects i did it by the
bootstraps and the seat of my pants i
didn't have any of this fantastic
information available to me so it's a
lot of fun to to be here with you
thank you everybody for uh joining us we
love having you here again take a look
at that link that i sent through the
chat for the upcoming webinars and
resources those are organized now
by uh
by discipline and then you can scroll
through and see all the various articles
and resources and upcoming webinars uh
in each one of the specific uh areas of
study so be sure and join as many of our
upcoming webinars as you can we love
having you here it's our way to give
back to the community and share the the
knowledge and wisdom of smes like tim
here
and with that said uh have a terrific
rest of your morning afternoon evening
if you were joining us from somewhere in
asia where it's the middle of the night
now man thank you for staying up late
and get to bed and with that said
thanks folks we'll see you next time
take care bye-bye
you